millions of people are waking up
thinking about how they can beat the
Thanksgiving travel rush triple-a
predicts more than 54 million Americans
will travel at least 50 miles away from
home between now and Sunday most of them
will drive but a record number is
expected to fly this holiday weekend is
predicted projected to be the busiest
for Thanksgiving travel since 2005 Kris
Van Cleave is in Washington battling
traffic on his way to the airport
Chris good morning good morning we are
finding the roads pretty open this
morning and for a lot of people leaving
today that's good news because it's
gonna get worse in cities like here in
DC Boston Detroit Seattle and Atlanta
this evening will be the worst for them
other places it will be Wednesday night
and if you're flying it's only getting
busier you're bringing the whole deal
yeah michael abreu 'no his wife their
two-year-old grandson Anthony and a
carload of food hit the road Monday to
beat the Thanksgiving rush on their
drive from New Jersey to Leland North
Carolina if we waited till Tuesday or
Wednesday
now you're starting to get the real
nasty travel days he's right
traffic is only going to get worse 48
point 5 million Americans are expected
to drive this year that's up about 5%
and comes despite the highest gas prices
since 2014 the economy is really
spurring this increase in travel we see
that consumer confidence that the 18
year high we also see that wages are up
Americans have more disposable income
they're taking that additional money and
putting it towards a trip with friends
and family this year triple-a predicts
Tuesday and Wednesday evening will be
the worse times to start your holiday
drive but it'll be Sunday where traffic
misery will peak not Sunday we made that
mistake last year again the airports
will be crowded two airlines are
expecting more than 2.5 million
passengers a day during the holiday
weekend we help out over the holiday
periods that's up from last year oh yeah
this is all hands on deck all hands ment
TSA administrator David pukowski helping
out at a Reagan National Airport
checkpoint
Sunday could set a record with the TSA
potentially screening more than 3
million fliers normally for us we're in
the low two million so I get up to 3
million and that's that's a significant
surge but if like the LeBron does you
need to take any entire Italian deli
with you drive which little Anthony
seems to like just fine gas prices are a
little higher than they were last year
but if ticked down some 30 cents over
the last month for drivers if you are
yet to leave Thursday morning
Thanksgiving morning is your best bet
for light traffic and flyers the TSA
says the most common mistake people make
at the checkpoints that really slows
them down is forgetting to take out your
liquids Nora I know kids for waiting
always gets it right say haven't you
flown before Kris Van Cleave are you
going to the airport because you're
taking a plane or because you're doing a
story
I'm doing both I'm taking a plane to a
story and they'll talk to you from
Chicago O'Hare tomorrow morning okay
just want to get in your business it
looks good it looks good